Well dying,
you know,
is uncomfortable.
I mean,
they have particularly these days,
even physically,
it's not fun people because of the power
of medicine,
people are living much longer.
They're living longer and accumulating
more burden of disease often.
And so they're dying in more pain than,
than people,
you know,
the early part of the last century.
Um,
dying over prolonged periods of time.
But then there's the inherently human
emotional pain,
existential pain of,
of dying,
which is,
you know,
again,
sort of part and parcel of the human
condition.
The fact that we are able to contemplate
our life and the meaning of our life and
to be so articulate within ourselves and
between people in the love that we have
for one another,
um,
imposes a downside of,
of knowing in such detail the,
the,
the extent of our losses,
the feeling,
uh,
emotionally,
the,
um,
the pain of losing people that we love
losing people for whom are,
uh,
are the most important things of our
life,
uh,
around whom our life revolves.
The notion of,
you know,
where am I going?
What happens after I'm not here?
There is a great deal of pain in having
lived and contemplating non life for
many people.
What's interesting is we,
even those,
uh,
most pure existentialists who
contemplate nonexistence and don't
believe in God or an afterlife,
uh,
feel the pain of nonexistence beyond
this life.
But if you ask them to contemplate it
time before they were born,
it has not nearly the amount of angst,
in other words,
existence before we were here has,
has none of the emotional charge of
existential annihilation beyond this
life.
Okay.